Okay, why don't we work through an example. Let's say
we had a CSV file located at this directory, and that
it contained a number of columns. Among them are a player's
name. We call that column, name. There's also a column called
handedness, L for left-handed R for right-handed, and a column
for the player's career batting average, called avg. Write a function
that will read that data into a Pandas data frame, and
then run Welch's t-test on the two cohorts defined by handedness.
With a significance level of 95%, if there
is no difference between the two cohorts, return
a tuple consisting of true, and then the
tuple returned by scipy.stats.ttest. If there is a difference,
return a tuple consisting of false, and then
the tuple returned by scipy.stats.ttest. So an example of
what your output might look like is false
and then the tuple 0.405, 0.006. Your code should
go here. Since we're using Welch's t-test, we're assuming our data
is sampled at random and that both samples follow a normal
distribution. We don't make any assumptions about the variance of both
samples. They may be the same, but they also may be different.